Film Courage: Why do most people fail at screenwriting?
John Truby: I think most people fail at screenwriting
because it’s the most difficult craft in
the world.
You know, people say talk about “I want
to be a director.”
Well, being a director is a very difficult
challenging job.
But it doesn’t compare to writing.
The craft of storytelling is the most complex
craft in the world.
It takes a lifetime commitment to master.
Now a lot of writers either don't realize
it’s going to take a lifetime of commitment
or they don’t want to face a lifetime of
commitment.
It’s a lot of work and that’s a lot of
time.
Most writers are looking for the magic bullet.
Which is why I talk about this in my class
all the time.
Most writers start off with this three act
structure-way of looking at storytelling,
which is designed for beginners and does not
work at the professional level.
The reason it’s so popular is because it
is a kind of magic bullet.
“It’s not that hard!”
Well, we’d all like to think that writing
a successful screenplay can be done with a
few simple steps, you know, a paint-by-numbers
approach.
Unfortunately it doesn’t work.
You have to be able to put in the work.
And you have to also realize that the level
of training that is required to get to a level
of excellence.
And that means literally hundred of craft
techniques that have to be mastered.
I will always tell writers in my class, plot
is the most underestimated of all the major
writing skills.
Most writers know the importance of a good
main character, they know the importance of
lean dialogue and so on.
But when it comes to plot, they think well
I’ll just figure that out as I go.
And of course that never happens because it
turns out that plot has more techniques that
must be mastered to become a working professional
than all the other major writing skills combined.
If you don’t know what those techniques
are, you have really no chance of working
at that level.
So that is why I say it is so important to
writers to not just getting trained, but getting
the right kind of training so that they are
working at the professional level.
And one of the key hallmarks that I’ve tried
to teach in all of my classes is that professional
writers use fundamentally different techniques
than all other writers.
If you don’t know what those professional
techniques are, you cannot play in that game,
you cannot compete at that level.
Film Courage: Do you think too that a lot
of people don’t realize that their temperament
is not suited [for being a writer].
I mean they are spending a lot of time alone.
You are having to be sort of self-generating.
And maybe people don’t realize how difficult
that is?
John Truby: You are absolutely right.
I consider the psychological element the biggest
obstacle to a writer’s success.
Because the difficulty of what you just said,
the difficulty of facing the page by yourself,
being in that room alone, trying to meet that
challenge, day-in-and-day-out, is very difficult
on the human mind.
And writers first of all don’t realize what
it’s going to take psychologically at first.
And then when they get into it and they try
to deal with that.
They really don’t have the tools or the
support system to be able to be in it for
the long haul.
I often tell writers that people who are professional
are the people who are still standing, you
know?
Everybody else…they were knocked out…for
various reasons, like they did not get the
right training.
But most of all they cannot handle the psychological
difficulties of what it takes to write at
the professional level.
Meaning, writing alone, facing rejection,
again and again, over many years and so on
until you have mastered the craft at a level
that somebody says “Hey, you’re a good
writer.
This is a good script.
I’m going to hire you.”
So it’s the people who A) commit to the
craft and B)
who are still standing who are there after
many years so that finally somebody says “Yeah,
you’ve done the work.
You’re actually pretty good.”
Because keep in mind, most people don’t
know a good story.
The just know [either] I liked it or I didn’t
like it.
But they are not trained as writers.
Again it’s the most complex craft in the
world.
So part of the difficult psychology is how
do you get over the fact that you’re getting
rejected from people who don’t know what
you do.
That’s very tough to face.
Film Courage: So which do you think is more
important, stubbornness or a teflon personality
where rejection just doesn’t define who
you are?
John Truby: I would say neither of those.
I would say both of those are dependent on
a previous requirement which is maintaining
an openness to learning the craft.
I will often get professional writers to take
my class and when I talk to them what I always
find is these people have no ego.
At least no ego coming across that I can see.
Because they are professional writers so you
would think that they think “Well I already
know this stuff!”
But they don’t.
They don’t take that attitude.
Yes, they are extremely well-trained.
If they get to the level of a professional
writer, they are extremely well-trained.
But these are people who are open to learning
more.
And I find that is the most important quality
for being a successful writer.
The willingness to learn from anywhere, anyone,
so that your repertoire, your arsenal, your
set of tools is constantly growing.
That (in turn) gives you the confidence to
say “That person didn't like my script,
but I know that it is based on the craft elements
that make for a good story.
So whether they liked it or not, that doesn’t
effect me.
I know it’s a good story.”
That’s where you get that foundation of
confidence that you need to get through those
tough psychological moments.
Film Courage: So almost as if, [let’s say]
an attorney or a doctor sort of mandatory
continuing education, artists some how feel
they are immune to this [same kind of training]?
“I’ve already learned what I need to learn…”
John Truby: Most do.
Most do.
And it’s a huge problem.
You know, when I give classes the most common
question is all about “How do I sell my
script?”
There’s an implication in that question
which is “I already know how to write a
good script.
The only thing I’m not able to do is sell
it.”
Not so.
99 percent of writers, will always talk in
Hollywood about, “It’s all about the connections.
It’s all about who you know.”
That is so overrated. 99 percent of writers
when they finally meet someone who is a useful
connection, they don’t have the story tools
to make that connection pay off.
They don’t have the craft foundation.
So it’s all about this ability to treat
writing as a profession.
And part of that is “I can never know enough
about how this craft works.”
And partly because every story is different.
I’ve talked to professional writer friends
who…we’re always amazed.
We think it’s going to get easier now.
It doesn’t!
It gets harder.
Because the better you get, the higher you
set the bar for yourself on your script.
Cracking a story is always hard no matter
how much you know because every story is totally
unique.
Yes there are certain elements you can use
that you can hang your hat on that you can
get a way into the story and so on.
But every one is tough.
So that’s why having this professional approach
to being a writer or being a storyteller is
so important because A) it makes you successful
B)
it gets you through.